[Musique]
le temps
une guitare une voix et un ami
violoncelliste meskerem metz a offert au
public une session folk lumineuse sans
fioritures
[Musique]
mais c'est une parolière de talent des
douze ans elle écrit ses premiers textes
[Musique]
il tire de la musique c'est une sorte de
thérapie gratuite pour moi ça a toujours
été ça et donc il y a des trucs qui me
passe ou qui passe dans ma vie
il y a des sentiments que je sens et je
comprends pas
super bien et alors j'écris au ces
sujets et après je me sens
plus à l'aise et super calme et libre en
fête
[Musique]
né en ethiopie elle grandit en belgique
des origines multiples qui lui inspire
une chanson
c'était toujours une sorte est
question difficile pour moi et j'ai
finir par
inventer une monde dans ma tête
pourrait être l'histoire de réponse à
cette question
digne héritière de joni mitchell mais ce
qui est à metz a conquis le public avec
ce folk pop enveloppant en seulement
quelques types
[Musique]